[Musique]
hariri dans la poche
rien à voir avec les crises de tigre
grelots greluche ça serait trop kitsch
non leur porte bonheur pour tester en
kit est devenu numérique leur amulette
contre coup de grisou état de choc et
relié au net il se grisent tous ces sons
des bises sur un écran bien à l'abri
dans leur repli sur un écran à caresser
ou à chérir à serrer fort en cas
d'urgence sérendipité dépit sérieux
pouvoir dans le caf ou de chant bien il
se crée des clips style jazz de 8 qui
essore la vie mieux qu'au lavomatic il
sale pas que la tête avec des pitchs
pour voyager façon iti téléphone maison
il wiki à tour de claviers
histoire de cibler une recette de
clafoutis chic
il passe au crible chaque réplique avant
de poster leur lot vitu d'ego type et
j'aime j'aime j'aime puis non je n'aime
plus petit risettes à la sauvette sitôt
cliquer site ozap et même pas passé par
le cerveau car désormais on a des tas d
maugis bonjour bravo aux tomates galette
dégueulis crotte de bique il ya qu'à
cliquer qu'à cliquer qu'à cliquer pour
huer ou applaudir ou se faire plaisir
pour s'inscrire au rang des érudits
jouer au récit de monsieur perrault
tient la chaire tablette la bimbo d'une
aide choura oh la la mère-grand comme
vous avez des grands pouces c'est pour
mieux te communiquer mon enfant c'est
quand qu'on existe dit c'est quand qu'on
se prend la tête
en aparté qu'on se dit je t'aime c'est
qu'on construit pour de vrai c'est quand
que tu m'intrigues c'est quand tu
m'invites est une jolie kermesse dédié à
la tendresse
je rêve de liesse au creux d'un carré
hermès je rêve tant caressé le ciel en
mai raflant les fesses aux chênes kermès
je rêve de garrigue et de riffs super
décibels spéciale dédicace à l'eau
répond moi non mais alors quoi je
voudrais de surprendre avec quelques
petits contenter ni tude mais pour
éluder ce que ce monde compte
d'absurdité il faudra tapoter longtemps
rien n'est pas de plus que ces
sempiternel papotage je compulse la
bibliothèque dans mon crâne et mon rib
rob goris et la zone est pourtant
illusion intuition sagacité fortuite je
le sais qu'on survit sans un radis chez
les inuit
alors si je te les cris pensera du que
j'ai pété un câble
aimant vira tu me faire cuire un oeuf à
la hitchcock à l'innocuité de ma
dernière idée
la vanité de cet univers milieu au
nombril ère où les dévots bave et où les
pitchouns sa fiche pour faire le mur
ils ont tous un grigri dans la poche a
tripoté pour ne pas se sentir piteux et
je m'apitoyais car désormais je ne suis
plus rien sur mon écran
jma malka monsieur n'est qu'amicale over
jour auquel chacun 400 grammes courtois
c'est la bagarre fut même charisme
amalgame chimiques à mme kemfert jours a
indiqué mme chapel holcat absents drame
croutoy c'est la bagarre j'ai mal garées
la prochaine fois via un autre homme et
si tu me bip sers toi plutôt d'un tam
tam
[Applaudissements]